6h du matin une perquisition est en
cours à son domicile et donc en sa
présence
il n'est en conséquence pas possible
pour celui-ci et pour des raisons vous
en conviendrez totalement indépendante
sa volonté de pouvoir honorer cette
convocation je vous prie de bien vouloir
m'accuser réception du présent mail et
vous prie d'agréer l'expression de ma
parfaite considération voilà le message
que nous avons reçu ce matin
et donc une partie une perquisition est
en cours chez monsieur cifaoui qui leur
retient évidemment
dans son domicile
dès lors cette audition n'aura pas lieu
évidemment avec le rapporteur nous le
regrettons et nous verrons comment nous
pouvons avancer dans ce dossier par la
suite je vous remercie nous vous
remercions d'être venu ce matin et je
vais vous libérer immédiatement